this show has done more than most to
expose the grifters at the lincoln
project and the disgusting depravity of
its co-founder john weaver
now one month ago we first brought you
the allegations that weaver made sexual
overtures to dozens of young men
and at least one minor for weeks the
lincoln project ignored this damning
story
well that until the new york times
picked it up of course the lincoln
project claimed to be shocked shocked i
say
about these revelations but now we know
it was all a lie
the ap reports that the lincoln project
was actually alerted to weaver's
perversion
back in june but instead of ousting
weaver well they stayed silent
maybe hoping no one would find out as
they raked in tens
of millions of dollars to line their own
pockets and make their stupid ads
the media was also complicit of course
even after weaver's grotesque behavior
was exposed
cnn and msnbc still invited these creeps
to come on and challenge
trump's character
the pathology of this man the ego
of this man this the sort of
depravity of because of a lack of
empathy this is a man with no empathy
with a low character we see all of
donald trump's character deficiencies
playing out in a in a magnified sense in
the middle of this we've gone from
caring about character rule of law where
are all those issues
by the way that was john weaver at the
end joining us now is the independent
journalist who really broke this story
ryan girdusky he's also the author of
the book they're not listening
ryan tonight the lincoln project
released a statement claiming
uh they're bringing in outside
investigators
that's a long wait for those outside
investigators
right it basically admits that they were
caught in a lie uh new york magazine
reports that
even steve schmidt and rick wilson said
that that that john
weaver was depraved and these go back
these go back to june 17th these
allegations
this is basically before this is while i
was starting the story on
and reporting on them and working on the
report against them
um june 17th and months went by before
he had his heart attack
and dismissed himself and then according
to the new york magazine he came back
and he was still messaging young men
while he knew i was working on a story
about him
that is how i mean everything the
lincoln project claimed donald trump was
was what they were doing and who they
are it is like looking in a mirror
everything they claimed that he was is
what they are
yeah i want to get to what you just
mentioned new york magazine
four lincoln project employees recall
weaver's behavior came
up repeatedly as a topic of discussion
one person remembers
schmidt and co-founder the odious rick
wilson telling people that
weaver was depraved and twisted and that
they wouldn't want to
know the truth about him the weaver
stuff is being taken care of
schmidt said according to another ryan
apparently
what took care of it was to quash the
story i imagine
that's what i'm guessing he didn't stop
him at all his behavior continued and it
continued under the lincoln project
umbrella
and they knew that something was wrong
but they didn't speak up
i mean most of their companies were
there their affiliate companies were
making
millions of dollars they didn't do
anything and now they're pretending that
they were
on top of it from the moment that it
happened they only spoke
up when they couldn't ignore the story
anymore when i replied
ryan i wanna i wanna i wanna jump in
here because you
you actually are intimating i believe
that
we haven't learned the worst of it what
can you tell
us tonight there is one young man
who i did speak to who has a
very serious allegation against john
weaver it is
a criminal allegation against john
weaver he will not come forward so i
cannot
tell his story for him um if
you are you know who you are you know
what you believe happened to you
and if you do come forward to that young
man i will support you 110
because it is horrendous what happened
um i
you know it is horrendous and the fact
that the mainstream media
continues to have them on and talk about
other things besides john weaver would
they have just lane maxwell on to talk
about
fashion or politics and joe biden
administration no
they knew they were silent they were
complicit
but at the end yeah but the goal was to
trash trump
and they got all these big big wig rich
people all across the country
to line their pockets to buy their
vacation homes to buy their
luxury whatever clothes
or cars or whatever the heck they do and
that was it the goal was to get trump
victims be damned allegations be damned
the goal was to get trump
and all these rich hollywood types who
gave them money
where are they speaking up for these
supposed victims where are they
where they should they should be they
should be interviewed i know reporters
who want to speak to them
of 87 million dollars raised about 50
million
50 of 87 million went to lincoln project
affiliated organizations
oh sorry affiliated company oh by the by
the group
uh by the group's founders all right
grifters
grifters grifters one and all ryan thank
you so much